I'd like you to remember with me and to
you that right you can pretty much
encapsulate everything you know about
values in a very very concise statement
right and it starts off like this
some want to stop you up finish me off I
need survival to me ID I need some
boundaries and then the integrand will
be now this case I could go either way
but you guys know it doesn't matter
right if I choose Y then that's going to
be X okay so excuse me what is this meat
what we're doing and um here's the first
place that I'm going to dig a little bit
deeper what we're doing is we are
considering the sum of a number of
infinitely small what kind of shape is
this it's a cylinder right that's why
these PI R squared H sort of thing comes
from yeah do you remember this wait a
minute
now this notation sort of disguises a
little bit what's going on we had to go
that can prove this and this is my first
step in a digging back deeper into what
volumes are I want to rewrite this but I
want you to remember what's actually
happening here what are the pieces right
the first thing is an using integral
notation and this DX business right we
try to we kind of treat we've been
treating DX particularly in rates of
change we've been treating it just kind
of like a regular number like part or a
fraction of the movie around all that
kind of thing for that reason I mean
it's partly true but we forget it's not
a whole number it's a normal number the
way of thinly as a normal number in that
if not right in fact what's going on is
there is a little bit involved okay now
I'm gonna change my labels a little bit
here just so that we can clarify this
really is about a cylinder okay that is
infinitesimally small I'm very you
saying look that I think is really a
height that is really a hind okay I live
hey the limit as H approaches here so
I'm gonna read able this H in a second
and then I am a D things up right I am
actually adding up an infinite series of
things that's what volumes is right so
I'm gonna go from some XML
yeah that and then of course in here
I've got my volume of a cylinder but ah
is what I'm going to be calling the
function of X and then I used to be
calling Y that's just the label but R is
a helpful to more local label I'd argue
because it tells you it's not just the
distance it's the radius of your
cylinder okay so we know this this is
fine
I want to show an example question which
takes this very simple idea of a
question you could do already but we're
gonna dig a bit deeper into we know what
if this is really what's underneath here
you can walk around with this as it were
you can take the engine out of the car
and put a new engine in there if you
know how it works if you lift the bonnet
and see what's going on so I need you to
draw a set of axes for me the set of
axes is gonna be I only knew I only need
the positive x side we weren't really
beyond the negative exercise so
what I'd like you to draw in here is our
parent curse and don't worry too much
about the scale the pair of curves I'd
like you to draw for me is y equals in
the x and y equals one of these so your
standard exponential curve that's just
fit in my hair because we look at
expedition breath in okay so draw that
guy in and also the standard rectangular
hyperbola water what we gonna do is I'm
using these guys we're going to generate
a volume out of this okay
now I want you to remember this idea and
of course if you wanted to you could
have swapped your X's and Y's what
effect did that have if I if I wrote it
down with X's and Y's and Y's it exit
very good I'm rotating around instead of
right here at the x-axis which is this
way I'll be rotating around the x-axis
right sorry the y-axis I just said okay
so alternatively I couldn't have this
the important thing to know about both
of these is that as a technique they are
limited to be around the coordinate axes
right that's kind of what you get out of
this I want to push on there and see if
we can get something different out of
this is there a question yes very good
so you've got your cylinders because the
rotation is going a whole different way
as I stood this way okay you're getting
syllabus in a different orientation okay
now here's the particular area I'd like
us to rotate around
we'll do the acceptors so if we go say
here and yeah I've actually got
interested in what these values are I'm
just gonna call it a and B the reason
why is because it's actually a bit icky
to deal with these numbers but it gives
us a really nice shape if I take this
region that's a bit leaning over beauty
if I take this region in here and if I
rotate around the x-axis my so and you
should have that of our showing the
rotation as well what kind of shape do I
get now being an uprated irritating
around this axis excuse me and I'm not
including the area beneath one on X I'm
going to get a hollow volume I'm gonna
get a volume with a hole in the middle
of it yeah
so do your best it might help if you
have a ruler because when you rotate
around this you ought to get a
symmetrical shape yes I should be
symmetrical according to my axis of
rotation so what you want to do probably
is really roll up just to help you get
it that more accurate diagram you want
to measure okay well what's this
distance here right on mine I have 11
centimeters because I have a comically
large diagram so if it's 11 centimeters
up when you read head around the
opposite edge will be 11 centimeters on
this side same to you with these two
spots they're gonna have their
corresponding bits there so that's just
a little help to make your diagram a
little more accurate so I hope you got
something roughly looking like this by
the way as you can see this is an
intensely visual topic almost the exact
opposite of what we're looking at
polynomials and integration so if you
don't have any other colors that you
bring with you routinely I would suggest
down to time to decide to bring some
colors with you because it just makes
your diagrams so so so much clearer and
things get clogged up very very quickly
okay now what I want you to notice is
that I am taking an area and rotating
that yes
taking area and retaining that now
ordinarily we would think okay the area
then I take and rotate to get a cylinder
the air I rotate
is this strip and it connects to the to
the x-axis or the axis of rotation so
there are no holes in it right so that's
why you get cylinder but because I have
this pot it's lifted off the axis if I
look at a particular area right if I
slice this across the axis of rotation
perpendicular to that I do not get a
cylinder I don't get any cylinders in
fact that's why I chose this particular
volume at these particular boundaries if
I were to go straight in to the
whiteboard right what kind of shape
would I get it's not a silly what is it
now a washer is a perfect word now maybe
you don't know what a Russian looks like
so I'm going to draw one for you and I
want you to draw them with me as well
let's choose a particular part of this
just because it's easy and it's been
highlighted for us why do we choose this
leftmost edge okay and just imagine a
tiny little slice of it that is you know
dx1 okay and what I'd like us to do is
just draw off over here to the
right-hand side